[Musique]
si les biberons n'était pas nécessaire
il fallait nous prévenir de ne pas faire
de bébés pendant le premier confinement
voici le type de message que des clients
de monoprix ont vu ce week end et
partager sur les réseaux sociaux une
campagne marketing pour se moquer des
mesures gouvernementales
celle ci indique que les vêtements pour
enfants jusqu'à 3 ans sont à nouveau
essentiel les autres sont prié d'arrêter
de grandir si c'est dur en ce moment
rassurez vous ça aurait pu être pire
vous pourriez de ce britannique déjà
atteint par le cos vider la dengue
aveugle et paralysé après avoir été
mordu par un peu bras royal
voyez ça aurait pu être pire était pas
si pourri que ça votre journée les chefs
d'entreprise n'en peuvent plus il faut
entendre cette colère et merci à nouveau
à cette chaîne de nous donner en rien
pas que nous les arrête et on peut dire
merci parce qu'il emmène au restaurant
la marque décathlon qui a décidé de
retirer ses publicités de la chaîne de
télévision sky news
c'est une décision qui est très
commentée sur les réseaux sociaux et une
décision annoncée par décathlon dans un
simple tweet en réponse à un internaute
je cite nous avons retiré nos publicités
de ses news
en cette fin d'année points pas plus
d'explications de la part de la marque
alors vous vous allez youtuber mais
plutôt extrême droite
ouais trop trump je pense que vit à côté
de mondes parallèles et la lune et
creuse on va marquer l'expert de chacun
a fait un peu n'importe quoi on a vu ce
qui est arrivé quand même qu'on le
veuille ou non
l'avez vous répéter pour
officiels et wil hahn une fois quelques
bons n'ont pas non plus les nazis s'il a
fini oui j'ai fini mes jeux non il n'a
pas fini
monsieur zouari julien courbet nous
sommes en direct sur la télé m6 monsieur
zouari a rien de grave on peut discuter
tranquillement c'est immense s'est
tellement désolant votre édition tout
con que je sais bien c'est tellement
désolant c'est un drame de ma vie d
argent cherchait des gens met plein les
poches sur le malheur des autres
départements oui ces bonbons les
emmerdes jeunes qui l'ont connu même si
sur l'autre moitié
alors maintenant une fois que vous avez
dit que je suis un escroc que je m'en
reste pas l'âge mais je le dis moi mais
monsieur je ne renie pas mes phrases ne
leur fait pas passer pour des méchants
mais je crois que c'est vrai nicolas
sarkozy que denis podalydès connaît bien
pour l'avoir interprété et toujours en
mouvement s'insurge exact dans son
attitude est ce que ce qui n'est pas
négatif qu'on attend dans la bouche de
barack obama serre que il ya quelque
chose qui entraîne après entraîner ou
c'est ça la question y aura-t-il un
desserrement pour les vacances réponse
de nicolas sark depardon d'emmanuel
macron demain à 20 heures le
gouvernement s'organiser prévoit de
consacrer aux vaccins 1,5 milliard
d'euros la france a déjà précommandé 90
millions de doses et acheté 50 super
congélateur pour conserver le vaccin à
moins 80 degrés du matériel stocké dans
des lieux extrêmement sécurisé et sous
alarme vous ayez des vaccins oui oui
gérard vous avez répondu oui monsieur
manigold je suis vacciné contre la
grippe et j'ai la chance d'être plus
donc je ne pense pas non plus vous
passez vous êtes vacciné parce que vous
êtes hop les ou non je situe à la grippe
aviaire pas de regard d'un foyer donc ça
alors vous savez les la fin de la
formule des psys les arguments n'existe
pas alors là on est plein dedans il ne
pensait pas se retrouver lui-même en
visio au milieu de tous les décideurs
européens
en fait c'est assez incroyable mais le
journaliste a obtenu les identifiants
pour rejoindre la réunion grâce à la
photo d'une ministre publié sur twitter
est supprimée depuis le ton est léger
ces sacs de sport il était consentant
voiture du chef puis les accuse de la
grossesse mais l'as beauvais alcoa aa à
aa
voilà la cible en question le noir celle
inverse pratiquement l'extérieur le feu
qui troue et moi le petit trou et noir
au milieu de la cible parce que j'en ai
vu plein de films que j'ai pas vu
c'était à quoi ça correspond à une
héroïne hémorroïdes c'est un peu ce
qu'on appelle un paquet vasculaire c'est
un regroupement de petites veines comme
on voit sur le sur l'animation dont le
rôle ça va être de gonfler et de venir
faire un rôle d'étanchéité au niveau de
l'anus et notamment pour éviter le
départ on va dire intempestives de gaz
ce qui peut quand même en société être
être un peu éméché non maintenant
tranquille encore du temps respire
cracpe est fait tout ce que tu veux
maîtres noachovitch il ya des règles de
décibels absolument on doit
effectivement faire du bruit
tout au moins en moins de 5 décibels si
c'est plus là ça devient un trouble
anormal de voisinage mais si belle
c'est un mot qui sature 8,7 sur l'ut je
vous embrasse
vous êtes ici bat à rousies oui depuis
un peu plus longtemps
c'est à dire oh je sais même plus à vous
comptez plus louer noront c'est là où
les femmes sont plus fortes que nous
complètement
c'est ça elles sont plus plus plus plus
chat plus de but qu'on prend les choses
comme elles viennent
joxe à cette phrase elle est formidable
j'ai une présence et de la truite
sauvage et pas du tout élevé quand c'est
pardon
ah j'aime pas la diva tumeur phase de
fer lit elle attendait une truite
éduquer elle était sauvage du coup elle
était pas
il s'est jeté à l'eau pour sauver son
chien des crocs d'un navigator 7 en
floride quel lieu cette scène
impressionnante devenue virale sur les
réseaux sociaux
le retraité de 74 ans parvient à ouvrir
suffisamment la gueule du reptile pour
libérer son cavalier king charles grâce
à lui
gunner est en bonne santé aujourd'hui
nous est là ça fera trois mêmes quatre
si je puis me permettre
car en fait notre agriculteur avait
prévu depuis longtemps de partir en
vacances avec son meilleur ami qui n'est
autre que son ex